do you find it upsetting that even
though you won three elections are still
a significant number of people within
the labor movement to view you as a
hindrance rather than a help to Labour's
election chances and are you planning on
sharing a platform with Ed Miliband at
any point during this campaign well as
I've just said to you about sharing
platform I'm delighted to be on many
platforms with that over a long period
of time and I just said that you
understand this and get this fully I
support him one hundred percent to leave
our party secondly you know one of the
things that I experience even when I
first became Labour leader is there's
there's always been disagreement within
the Labour Party and different people
who have different views about how we
should approach things but the important
thing is what we share in common right
and what we share in common is a deep
and profound belief in social justice in
the belief that it is the purpose of a
Labour government to bring opportunity
to those people that don't have it and I
believe also that it is right that our
society in our country and its economy a
run in the interests of the many are not
the few and those are values that unite
the Labour Party they're what keep us
strong and then what should see us on
course for a general election victory or
may the seven